sound like you needed those four years
to find out maybe what you didn't want
and then yes exactly it was great I
don't regret it because it really showed
me what I wanted and sometimes you know
you never know what's going to show you
that in life
sure well starting out for someone today
since it's much more competitive yes
would you recommend would you recommend
of course interning and then how would
someone prove that they were worthy of
promoting yes I would recommend
interning and I'd recommend working as a
PA and I'd recommend theirs well I think
that one thing I've noticed is that
there's so many things but I'm fine I
think what to say first you have to know
that it's the right thing for you so in
that sense I mean you have to be willing
to work very long hours you have to be
willing to it's a tough business and
there's a lot of hierarchy and there's a
lot of personalities and you have to be
able to cope with that you can't be too
sensitive you know it's hard that's a
learning curve you have to be patient I
think you should always be working below
your skill level I think that working
you know at a level at which you're not
really qualified for is just going to be
a bit mistake in your career and I made
that mistake I took a job as a prop
master I didn't know what I was doing I
got fired you know and it taught me a
lesson
so I think you should always be aware
that should always be kind of more
prepared for than you then you should be
for the job I think a lot of people just
out of college are impatient I don't
blame them they want to get started they
want to be this or that but I think
there's so much to learn and you should
make your mistakes when no one's gonna
see them and yeah I designed student
movies I designed a student movie that
took place in 1968 and I filled it with
every piece of kitsch from 1968 that I
could think of you know if I would never
do that now as a designer and I did that
on a student movie that nobody ever saw
and I'm glad I got that out of my system
so you're gonna make mistakes make them
when nobody's watching
don't make them when someone's watching
and I might not hire you the next time
so I think patience hardwork ambition
not taking it you know not
being too sensitive those are just
character traits and they're really
important for this business and then on
top of that you know watch a lot of
movies and look at a lot of art and look
a lot of photography and know what
you're talking about because it's not
just about design it's about cinema I
mean to me it's about cinema and it's
about designing a movie it's not about
designing a set so the directors I meet
with they want to talk about other
movies you know they don't want to talk
about building a set and I think that
that's the most important thing for any
of us working at a creative level in
this business is we're working on movies
and whatever kinds of movies we want to
work on you know everybody's got their
things some people want to do superhero
movies and some people want to do
low-budget period movies and some people
want to do romantic comedies everybody
or fantasy movies it's you know
everybody's got their thing that they
want to do but know that know that genre
that you're working in or know that that
group of films because all films inform
the next film that comes along and and
you have to love it so it's you know
everything that I do in my life is
really related to my work and I can't
really separate it when I go on vacation
I'm taking photographs of signs that I
might use as research in a movie and I
enjoy it it's not like we turn it off
because I'm done with my job it's
ongoing and it's worth it but you have
to love it
you